my name is shauna coxey and i'm a
professional climber and i'll be
competing in sport climbing for the
first time
climbing's first time at the tokyo 2020
games
when sport climbing makes its olympic
debut this summer
shauna coxy will be reaching for gold
the two-time world champion's been
competing since the age of seven
climbing at the games is called sport
climbing and it's a combination
of three different disciplines which are
speed climbing self-explanatory how fast
can you get up the wall
bouldering which you can see a little
bit behind us climbing not too high off
the ground above maps
and then also lead climbing which is
clipping a rope in as you climb up and
it's who gets the highest
the overall winners based on who
performs best in all
three disciplines it's a full body sport
legs core arms fingers
everything needs to be strong but this
isn't just about
punishing routines team great britain's
approach
before they even get to the wall is
about
fun
if you're in a joyful place and you're
happy to just let go and have a go then
it's going to help you on the wall
because if you're comfortable with
pushing your boundaries and feeling a
little bit uncomfortable on the floor
and learning on the mat you'll be able
to then do that on the climbing wall
the philosophy behind all of this is
about training through
play no stuffy training rituals here
a happy body leads to a happy mind leads
to a happy athlete
strength and agility are only half the
story climbers also need a strategic
mind to tackle any configuration of war
so in one of the competitions the
athletes are only given a matter of
minutes
in isolation to work out how to plan
their routes
[Music]
it's about their bodies and their minds
working in sync
this has of course been an unusual year
with athletes from many sports having to
adapt their training routines during the
pandemic
with climbing centers closed shauna used
a specially built wall
in her own basement as athletes
adjusting is something we're familiar
with
we adjust to injury we adjust the
changes in events and
that's part of our lives so in a way
yes it was surreal to have to adjust but
it's also something that is familiar
the sport's all about the athlete's
personal interaction with the wall
but there's a collective zeal amongst
these climbers a sporting euphoria
even when things go wrong
getting a competitive edge over her
rivals in games where the margins
between athletes are minuscule
take shauna away from the wall to an ice
cold river in the english countryside
after being indoors in the climate all
day to come out and
feel connected with the outdoors again
is important
this is the athlete's place to unwind
focus
and prepare body and mind for the lofty
heights of the olympic games
giving the less athletic amongst us a
moment to cool off sore limbs
never al jazeera sheffield